trevor's story last night a double on a
home run to run his current hitting
streak to nine
and this is blue to shallow left and he
hit it in the right place a base hit for
story
bellinger was on three times last night
he had a base hit and walked twice
still looking for that first extra base
hit this month
flips his ball to right center field par
is on the move he turns and watches it
go just over the wall in right center
cody bellinger with a two-run home run
his first extra base hit of september is
his 11th home run of the season and it
gives the dodgers an early two-nothing
lead edwin rios who's hit a home run in
each of his last two games one-two pitch
rios swats it through the left side
beating the shift for the base hit down
the line
he's trying for two here's dahl's throw
not in time and a hustle double for
edwin rios everybody brings lux to the
plate
he unloads on a ball forget about it
two-run shot
into the second deck for gavin lux
and boy was that powerful
third home run of the season snaps an o
for 14 and makes it four nothing in the
second inning
stop there's one on the first i think
they double them up they did
great play by story to start a six four
three so the rockies with runners on the
corners
and josh fuentes up
against alex wood
and this ball hammer deep left field
take a good look you won't see it for
long rockies right back in this thing
josh fuentes a three-run bomb
third first and second for seeger
pulls it sharply to second mcmahon
throws wildly
and everybody's safe
dodgers trying to make it hurt now bases
loaded one away and up comes chris
taylor the base is loaded chris taylor
swings away and rips a line drive base
hit to left
his scores one
it scores two and the dodgers lead 6-3
on a two-run single from chris taylor on
c with runners at first and second and
one out
muncie yanks one down the line base hit
to right that pitch was bearing in on
his knuckles and he fought it off for an
rbi hit seeger into score taylor to
third and it's 7-3 that dugout is having
some fun aren't they first and third one
out for bellinger
he pulls it through the right side
another hit for him and another run for
the dodgers as taylor comes in an rbi
single for cody bellinger it's 8-3
second four-run inning tonight still
only one out hitters pollock on a 3-1
pollock
swats a ground ball base hit to right
muncie is headed for the play throw goes
to third bellinger's safe muncie's in
it's 9-3 as paddock drives one in
four consecutive singles for the dodgers
four consecutive rbi singles for the
dodgers
top of the order
extended the amber streak with the walk
is last time it's now 18 consecutive
games reaching on a one-one offer in
bets it's a towering fly ball to deep
left field dahl back to the wall
out of room and gone
just barely enough
the question was when would it come down
and then when it did would it have
enough on it and it did number 16 of the
season for mookie bets taylor's driven
in two of those ten runs
taylor smashes the line drive to deep
center field polar with a diving attempt
but it comes out
oh superman effort
unable to squeeze it seeger's into score
on a double from chris taylor david just
won for 13
on the home stand
that's a hard hit and it's fair down the
right field line so dahl's got a knock
there pilar is going to score
here comes fuentes he gets a green light
he'll score easily it'll be a triple for
dahl 11-5
rbi's eight and nine for david
elias diaz fly ball to right and uh
ground ball to third and this ball lined
to center field it'll get down base hit
dahl scores it's 11-6
base hit left field to bring home
ballinger
second hit of the game for edwin rios
it's 12-6 new season high and runs for
the dodgers
lux at third barnes and second way davis
getting ready to deal the eighth pitch
to mookie bets here comes
the hangers lifted to left center field
polar racing to the gap still in the
move won't get there and mookie's ribbon
in two more
on his way to third
he adds a triple to his home run the
dodgers lead 14-6 let's dear seeger
rip to the right side base it for seeger
bets in to score and it's 15-6
rockies down to their last strike as
white fires mcmahon hits a bouncing ball
to lux in short right and that
will do it dodgers biggest offensive
night of the season they score 15 runs
to win their fourth straight